it's election season in kenya
raila rodinga has run for president four
times before he launched his manifesto
at an event in the capital nairobi will
declare corruption
a threat to national security and
establish a specialized department
in the security agencies for corruption
surveillance
this
we shall do within our first 100 days in
office reil has been involved in
politics since the 1980s mostly in
opposition
he's never been declared the winner of
an election although many believe he's
been rigged out of victories before this
time some things have changed it's the
first time that ryla redinger is running
with the support of the incumbent
outgoing president kenyatta with the
support of the families that have
dominated kenyan politics and business
ever since independence from british
colonial rule
nearly 60 years ago the first time that
he's the chosen candidate of the
historically dominant political
establishment
it's the kind of backing that his main
rival william ruto had once hoped for
he's been deputy president in the last
two governments
ten years ago ruto teamed up with uhuru
kenyatta at the time both were facing
charges at the international criminal
court for orchestrating crimes against
humanity in the violence that followed
the previous election in 2007.
the charges were later dropped after
witnesses retracted their statements
uhuru and ruto's relationship since
deteriorated
running without the support of his
former ally
in spite of being in government for nine
years he's now promising change
our problem is inequality our economic
model in the last five decades has been
trickled down type which has only
benefited the few creating halves and
have not who are just hustlers we aim to
change this economic model
kenya's past elections have been marred
by irregularities allegations of rigging
and sometimes violence
this time allegiances have shifted and
factions realigned
kenyans are due to vote on the 9th of
august malcolm webb al jazeera nairobi
kenya